Yeah,
in terms of associates who've been
differed from their law firm jobs,
uh,
I think that,
well,
I guess I would say a couple of things.
First be patient.
You will start eventually,
hopefully.
Uh,
there had been a couple of cases of law
firms that,
that told associates who thought they
had jobs will actually you no longer
have a job,
but most firms seem to be honoring that
commitment.
Um,
the second thing I would say is a focus
on developing your professional skills.
So if you are working in a public
interest organization for that time,
really take the ball and run with it,
see what kind of responsibilities you
can get.
You might be able to get more
responsibilities during the public
interest year that you are awaiting out
waiting to start for the law firm than
you will as a junior associate at a law
firm.
So the second thing I would say is
really try to make the most of your
time.
And the third thing I would say is enjoy
your time.
You will have a lifetime to work and if
you want to work at a firm and a,
you could work for decades,
you know,
if you make partner or if you moved to
another firm,
if you don't make partner,
you could work at a law firm.
And one thing that's nice about lawyers
is it is a very,
it is a mental discipline.
Granted there are physical demands as
well,
but it's not like were baseball players.
We can work into our sixties,
into our seventies so you will have your
whole life to work and if you are
deferred right now and you are either at
your leisure or if you're working at a
job,
say at a public interest organization
with reasonable hours,
enjoy it.
Have dinner with your wife or husband or
boyfriend or girlfriend.
Go on vacation.
Do the things that you might not be able
to do once the economy turns around and
you're at a firm and you're billing
2,500 hours a year.
So I guess that will be my advice.
We actually have a series on the blog
called career alternative is where we
focus on,
uh,
interesting things that people who have
law degrees are doing that don't involve
working at a law firm.
So,
uh,
one thing that's nice about one silver
lining,
I guess to the recession generally as
people are coming up with business
ideas,
partly because perhaps they lost their
lucrative,
stable job at a big company and now they
have to come up with something else.
Um,
so we've talked,
we've talked to lawyers who have started
tutoring and uh,
admissions consulting businesses,
a lawyer who has started a cupcake
business,
he drives around Manhattan in a truck
selling cupcakes.
We have talked to lawyers who have done
all kinds of things.
There's a lawyer who owns a chain of
subway sandwich stores and a lot of
them,
even though they're not necessarily
using their legal training,
we'll talk about how valuable it is to
have that kind of education,
the critical thinking skills,
the communication,
the ability to look over a contract when
they are trying to launch their
businesses.
These are all things that help.
So granted,
a law degree is expensive and so if
you're thinking about going to law
school,
I would urge you to think very carefully
about it,
but once you have that degree,
it is quite versatile.
We've looked at lawyers who've gone into
public relations,
who've gone into journalism,
who've gone into finance.
There are a lot of things you can do
with a law degree.
I think it's a great credential to have.
I think it's a great education.
There is just a question of bang for
your buck because there are a lot of
other things that are good to have,
but do you want to spend $200,000 for
them?